А тепер в ефірі «heute jornal» з Гайнцем Вольфом
і Марієттою Сломкою.
Доброго вечора! Багато хто зараз з хвилюванням
очікує на зиму.
Зокрема, хвилює питання газопостачання.
Чи зможемо ми забезпечити опалювальний сезон?
Але до холодів на нас чекає
ще одна хвиля спеки.
Наступного тижня в Європі, також у Німеччині,
спека буде настільки сильною,
що становитиме загрозу життю літніх та хворих людей.
Однак, такі хвилі спеки є лише одним боком медалі.
Також це літо знову надто посушливе,
а в деяких частинах Європи вже
була надто посушлива весна.
Також взимку випало дуже мало снігу.
Тому бракує талої води, яка наповнює річки.
Через це в Італії Паданська рівнина
зараз практично висохла.
Лара Відекінґ розповість про
наслідки посухи в Німеччині.
Нестачу вологи видно не одразу.
На ділянці спілки садівників
«Tiefe Wiese» вирощують квіти та овочі.
Юта Дреґер та її чоловік
створили тут справжній зелений рай.
Зараз їм доводиться ощадливо ставитись до води,
раніше такого не було.
Тут встановили обприскувач
і приєднали його до крану.
І ніхто не зважав на те,
що частково це нісенітниця,
адже я розумію,
що мені не потрібно зволожувати листя картоплі,
я можу просто зробити рівчачки,
щоб вода стікала в них.
На південь від Маґдебурґа.
Тут йшов дощ.
На полі фермера Еккегарда
Горманна земля є дещо виснаженою.
Але справжня проблема - глибше.
Тут вже помітно, що земля значно твердіша
і помітно сухіша.
Не лише червень був надто
сухим, вже з 2018 року дощило мало.
За словами Горманна, рівень води
в цьому регіоні
знизився майже на два метри.
Це сумно. Адже рослини закорінюються
не лише на 20 см.
Довжина коренів пшениці сягає, наприклад, 1,8 м.
Саме на такій глибині вона отримує воду
та поживні речовини.
Але там, де нічого немає, не може бути врожаю.
Наслідок один: рослини дозрівають раніше,
врожайність зменшується.
«Нашим найбільшим резервуаром води
є ландшафт,
і жодне водосховище його не замінить», - стверджує
Доктор Карстен Рінке
з Центру Гельмгольца щодо екологічних досліджень.
Водночас ущільнені поверхні є великою проблемою.
Ми повинні потурбуватися про те,
щоб більша частина опадів просочилася в землю
пройшла крізь пісок і ґрунтові води,
порівняно швидко відокремилась,
а далі порівняно швидко потрапила до водотоку,
а через дев'ять днів опинилась у морі.
Посуха виснажує також високі дуби
та хвойні дерева.
Вони стають вразливішими на шкідників і хвороб.
І наслідки цієї посухи спостерігаються ще довго.
Як показує досвід, вплив посухи
на немолоді лісові дерева є досить довготривалим,
а, отже, навіть якщо
ситуація з опадами покращиться,
досить мало дерев відновляться.
Посуха вражає велику частини Німеччини.
Брак дощу є частиною природних погодних коливань.
Однак зміни клімату, спричинені людиною,
погіршують ситуацію.
Звичайно, фази засухи і вологості
також є і в звичайному кліматі,
але є дещо, що сильно змінилося
і змінюватиметься через зміну клімату:
тепер літо є спекотнішим, ніж було б без
змін клімату,
і процес триватиме.
І через цю спеку дощ швидше випаровується,
а вода зберігається менше часу.
У районі Штендаль безперервний полив заборонений.
Власниця маленького саду Юта Дреґер
знайшла правильне рішення в часи посухи.
Запитаймо в Оздена Терлі:
якою буде хвиля спеки наступного тижня?
З півдня надійде гаряче повітря.
З боку Іспанії в бік Франції.
Це перша хвиля, посеред тижня
температура сягатиме 35°.
Ближче до вихідних буде ще спекотніше.
Очікуємо на екстремальні температури, 40° і вище.
Нам слід почекати, щоб оцінити ситуацію повністю.
35° прогнозуємо до середи, на півночі буде не так
спекотно, як на південному заході.
У Кельні, наприклад, температура сягатиме 40°.
Ми розглянули середні температурні показники,
тобто подекуди буде спекотніше.
Поки слід почекати,
до наступного тижня ще багато часу.
Хвилі спеки зазвичай спостерігаються влітку.
Чи є ця хвиля вже-ж незвичною?
Хвилі спеки стають частішими
під час кліматичної кризи.
Так стверджують науковці.
Ми маємо графік для Німеччини,
де позначено спекотні дні.
Їхня кількість зростає,
протягом десятиліть їх більше й більше.
Це очевидний розвиток, хвилі спеки збільшуються
в тривалості,
інтенсивності та частоті.
Очевидно, що спека дедалі більше посилюється,
метеорологи прогнозують зростання температури, та,
відповідно, збільшення кількості
екстремальних погодних явищ до кінця десятиліття.
Часті та тривалі періоди посухи призводять до падіння
обсягів врожаю у всьому світі
та ставить під загрозу продовольче забезпечення.
Крім цього, голодом зловживають як
інструментом влади.
Війна в Україні не лише перешкоджає
експорту зерна
до Африки та Близького Сходу.
Росіян звинувачують і в тому,
що вони крадуть запаси зерна
і навмисно підпалюють поля.
Проте Росія веде продовольчу війну не тільки в Україні.
Також і в Сирії.
Через Росію в повстанських районах
на північному заході Сирії останній
гуманітарний коридор, ймовірно, буде закрито.
Мандат ООН, який уможливлював
перевезення гуманітарних вантажів
через турецько-сирійський кордон,
сьогодні вночі стане недійсним.
Росія заблокувала його продовження
в Раді безпеки ООН.
Про це повідомляє Бриґітта Саар.
Навіть зараз їй часто ледве вистачає на життя.
Фатім - вдова.
Разом з онуками живе в таборі біженців
на околицях Алеппо.
Вона не має власного доходу.
Як і мільйони переселенців у регіоні,
життя жінки залежить
від гуманітарної допомоги,
яку доставляють через пункт пропуску Баб аль-Хава.
Якщо кордон закриють, це буде справжня катастрофа
для нас, для всіх, хто тут перебуває.
Тоді люди скрізь битимуться за їжу.
Також Таха Аслан, завідувач складом
літав на війні перед військами Асада.
З великим клопотом він отримав доручення
у Раді Безпеки від Росії
щодо доставки гуманітарної допомоги в столицю,
а звідти розподілити під контролем Асада.
У разі закриття пункту пропуску
сюди надходитиме набагато менше допомоги.
Це буде справжня гуманітарна катастрофа.
Надзвичайно небезпечно
давати режиму контроль над гуманітарною допомогою.
Це для нас наче ляпас.
Крім того, місцеві продукти ставатимуть все дорожчими.
Ахмед - фермер у регіоні Алеппо,
він вирощує пшеницю, кукурудзу та овочі.
Цього року врожай поганий.
Був град і передусім мало дощу.
Він намагається виправити ситуацію за допомогою
штучного добрива та водяної помпи,
що працює на паливі.
Ми збираємо лише половину,
а витрати різко зростають.
Війна між Росією та Україною
робить набагато дорожчим не лише добриво.
Голод і недоїдання
поширюються все далі в регіоні,
особливо це стосується наймолодшого населення.
Тому що на кону стоїть дитяче харчування.
Здається, ця потреба не береться до уваги
в політичній суперечці
щодо шляхів забезпечення гуманітарної допомоги.
Ми можемо лише сподіватися,
що вони знайдуть альтернативу
у разі закриття пропускного пункту.
У нас тут тисячі дітей, жінок та вразливі групи,
чиє життя залежить від цього.
Майбутнє народу на північному заході Сирії
є найбільш невизначеним за всі часи.
Якщо Росія в Радбезі ООН не піде на поступки,
то на цих вихідних втратить чинність постанова,
завдяки якій пропускний пункт Баб аль-Хава
був відкритий для гуманітарної допомоги.
Тож останній маршрут для незалежної
гуманітарної допомоги
припинить своє існування.
Тим часом війна в Україні продовжується.
Російська пропаганда
набуває дедалі гостріших рис.
Навіть не потрібно знати російську,
щоб на власні очі побачити,
що продукує російське телебачення.
Наприклад, у Твіттері є облікові записи,
які регулярно публікують «підбірку найкращого»
із субтитрами.
Після перегляду відчуття шоку через те,
що говорять прибічники Путіна.
Особливо виділяються двоє ведучих:
Маргарита Симоньян, головна редакторка
пропагандистських каналів RT і Sputnik,
яка не втомлюється заперечувати будь-яке право
України на існування,
і Володимир Соловйов, який вже одного разу закликав
щонайшвидще напасти на Німеччину,
поки її збройні сили нібито ще слабкі.
Детальніше розповість Крістіан Земм.
Майже щовечора Володимир Соловйов,
один із найвидатніших агітаторів Путіна,
веде своє велике пропагандистське шоу на
державному телебаченні.
На цих шоу відкрито погрожують війною Німеччині,
а західних політиків називають зневажливими словами
та приписують їм усілякі звинувачення.
У цьому випуску йдеться про
президентку Єврокомісії Урсулу фон дер Ляєн.
Фон дер Ляєн говорить про європейські цінності
й про те, що Україна, на її думку, виграє цю війну.
А потім Соловйов прирівнює ці слова до нацизму.
«Не вистачає лише одного -
вигукнути нацистське вітання і струнко стати!» -
каже ведучий.
Він запитує:
Урсуло, ти розумієш, що за дурниці ти говориш?
Потім він звертається до Німеччини:
Ви звикли,
що Німецькому Рейху служить молодший брат,
український «рейх».
Бандера - це вірний послідовник німецького фюрера
Адольфа Гітлера.
Як ця постійна пропаганда й розпалювання ворожнечі
на телебаченні впливає на росіян?
Цей пан пророкує нашому російському співробітнику
важке майбутнє, якщо він і надалі
дотримуватиметься такого ж курсу на
німецькому телебаченні.
Це відкрита погроза, проте не всі піддаються пропаганді.
Це все відверта брехня. Я не знаю, чи він сам
у неї вірить.
Соловйова журналістом дуже важко назвати.
Як на мене, люди зазвичай черпають інформацію
з Youtube і Telegram, а старше покоління, можливо,
із телебачення.
Цілими днями на державних телеканалах
звучить одне і те ж:
Захід начебто занепав через своїх нікчемних політиків
та фейкові ЗМІ,
ліберальна модель суспільства в Європі та США
провалилася,
а німці нібито замерзають
через власні ж санкції.
Інформаційні війська Путіна є головною
опорою режиму.
Вони важливіші, ніж правоохоронні органи
та органи безпеки.
Пропаганда забезпечує лояльність народу.
Вона гарантує надійність в тилу, а це найважливіше.
Усіляка критика придушується.
Той, хто публічно дискредитує російську армію,
може опинитися у в'язниці.
Наприклад, у п'ятницю московського депутата
Олексія Ґорінова
засудили до семи років позбавлення волі,
тому що на засіданні муніципальної ради
він назвав російську «військову операцію» війною.
Хворий на туберкульоз Ґорінов навіть під час
винесення вироку пише на листочку запитання:
«Вам ще потрібна ця війна?».
Його родина та прихильники аплодують,
він не має наміру відмовлятися від своїх слів.
60-річний чоловік також додає:
Вони забрали в мене весну, вони забрали в мене літо,
а тепер вони забрали в мене сім років життя.
Фьобе Ґаа зараз у Москві.
Критиків ув'язнюють, тоді як пропагандисти стають
усе активнішими.
Для нас це відверто дивно.
Наскільки ця пропаганда спрямована на Захід,
щоб залякати нас?
На мою думку, ці російські ток-шоу
орієнтовані саме на місцеву аудиторію.
Метою є довести росіян до стану тривоги,
щоб нікому не спало на думку що-небудь
поставити під сумнів.
Щоб тривога не спадала,
ці передачі мають ставати щораз агресивнішими.
Автори пропагандистських шоу, ймовірно, розуміють,
що це не діє на аудиторію демократичних країн,
тому для дезінформування Заходу
та поширення проросійських наративів
Росія має є інші інструменти й канали.
Після початку війни бюджет державних ЗМІ,
до яких належить, зокрема, канал RT,
збільшився втричі.
Це показує, наскільки важливими
для досягнення путінської мети
є ЗМІ.
Попри це, Путін має бути зацікавлений у тому,
щоб населення,
передусім у Москві та Санкт-Петербурзі,
у повсякденному житті якомога менше чуло
про так звану «спецоперацію».
Чи вдається йому це?
Лише частково, адже, з одного боку,
більшість солдатів, зокрема й загиблих,
походять з російської глибинки, тому гнів і відчай,
які могли б перерости в протести,
залишаються далеко за межами мегаполісів.
Проте з іншого боку, перші наслідки санкцій
найбільш відчутні саме в Москві,
Санкт-Петербурзі або в інших російських
містах-мільйонниках.
Тут живуть люди, які за останні роки,
чи навіть десятиліття,
звикли до відпусток за кордоном,
до американських смартфонів та німецьких автомобілів.
І тепер вони змушені або відмовитися від цього
задоволення, або платити за нього більше.
Мер Москви припускає, що наступного місяця
25 тис. жителів Москви втратять роботу через те,
що західні компанії залишають місто.
У інших мегаполісах ситуація, однозначно, буде схожою.
Наша кореспондентка з Москви. Дякую, Фьобе.
Про війну та її наслідки розповість Гайнц.
А саме про постачання російського газу
трубопроводом «Північний потік-1».
Попри санкції, уряд Канади хоче повернути
турбіну для газопроводу, який ремонтувався.
Росія скоротила постачання газу трубопроводом
«Північний потік-1»,
пояснивши це, зокрема, відсутністю турбіни.
Про те, як буде надалі з поставкою газу
цим трубопроводом
ми поговоримо в кінці випуску.
У разі, якщо енергоносіїв у Німеччині не вистачатиме
та вони подорожчають настільки, що люди
не зможуть за них платити,
міністерка захисту прав споживачів
Лемке намагатиметься
не допустити того, щоб їм відключали електроенергію чи газ.
У неділю виданню «Bild» вона сказала,
що у разі кризи варто буде погодити ще
один пакет допомоги.
Російська армія
продовжує атакувати Схід України,
передусім Донецьку область.
Там, у місті Часів Яр, унаслідок
ракетного обстрілу росіянами житлового будинку,
за українськими даними, загинуло 15 осіб.
Ще більше 20-ти людей, імовірно, залишається
під завалами.
Після поразок на виборах, сексистського скандалу
та кризи в керівництві партії Лівих її співголова Шірдеван
хоче вивести партію з тривалої кризи.
У «ZDF-Sommerinterview» він заявив,
що країна наразі переживає екзистенційну кризу
і потребує, нарешті, сильних Лівих,
які б «підштовхували» уряд до дій.
Тому партія зосередилася на тому,
щоб «знову стати впізнаваною
серед громадськості».
Я хочу,
щоб керівництво моєї партії
всюди обстоювало ті позиції,
які ми демократично погоджуємо.
Повне інтерв'ю ви знайдете онлайн на heute.de.
Після оголошення про відставку президента
і прем'єр-міністра до Шрі-Ланки знову
повернувся спокій.
У столиці Коломбо люди захопили
президентський палац і мирно розвідують,
які зручності він має.
Учора більше 100 тис. людей вийшли на вулиці
в знак протесту проти дотепер найгіршої
економічної кризи
та корумпованого уряду.
Тепер вони вимагають повного оновлення уряду.
Під час своєї подорожі до Азії
Анналена Бербок сьогодні зупинилася в Японії.
Країна досі шокована
після вбивства колишнього прем'єр-міністра Сіндзо Абе.
Пригніченості настрою міністерки додав також
візит до Нагасакі,
де вона відвідала музей, присвячений пам’яті про
атомне бомбардування міста з боку США 1945-го року.
Це відповідає нинішній ситуації,
коли всі спостерігають, як далеко може зайти
така ядерна держава, як Росія,
і чи зможе Захід протистояти їй.
У Східній Азії за цим уважно стежать.
Зрештою, Китай також є ядерною державою
із неабияким апетитом.
На Тайвані багато хто побоюється,
що їм загрожує сценарій, подібний до українського.
Про це розповість Міріам Штаймер.
Це схоже на відеогру, проте насправді це навчання
на випадок надзвичайної ситуації.
Уейн Ян тренується тут уже протягом кількох тижнів.
Раніше він ніколи не тримав зброю в руках.
У повсякденному житті Уейн Ян
займається торгівлею спортивними тренажерами.
Я взагалі не був знайомий зі
зброєю і хотів дечому навчитися,
щоб у разі війни я міг допомогти.
Причиною його рішення став напад Росії на Україну.
Війна викликала занепокоєння у тайванців,
що Китай може вчинити так само, як Росія.
Я дуже хвилююсь через війну в Україні.
У новинах я бачив,
наскільки сильним і ефективним є опір українців.
Якщо ми всі згуртуємось,
тоді й у нас все може вийти.
Саме тому я вирішив пройти вишкіл.
Відтоді кількість охочих долучитись до військових навчань
в передмісті столиці Тайбей зросла в чотири рази.
У навчання включено
стрільбу, самооборону і першу допомогу.
Сюди приходять люди з досвідом у військовій
або поліцейській справі, а також ті,
хто не мав до цього жодного стосунку - серед них
дедалі більше жінок.
Китай також проводить тренування -
маневрами поблизу Тайваню китайські військові
грають м'язами і
«репетирують» возз'єднання.
Так це називає китайський
президент Сі Цзіньпін.
Для нього демократичний острів - китайська територія.
Його мета: повернути норовливого «брата».
Нещодавно Китай з усіма почестями
освятив свій третій авіаносець,
назва якого - «Фуцзянь».
Це назва також китайської провінції,
розташованої прямо навпроти Тайваню.
Ці кадри з Китаю спонукали тату-майстра Су Чуна
також готуватися до можливого нападу Китаю.
Тепер замість голки він все частіше тримає
пневматичну зброю.
Звичайно, більшість людей не хочуть воювати,
і я також не хочу,
але, якщо війна дійсно почнеться,
я буду морально до неї готовий.
Це не лише особиста ініціатива тайванців.
Уряд також зацікавлений
посилити військовий потенціал.
Військовий обов'язок, раніше скорочений до 4 місяців,
може бути знову подовжений.
Більшість вважає це правильною ідеєю і
продовжує готуватися до найгіршого розвитку подій.
А тепер Гайнц з новинами спорту.
Розпочнемо з Формули 1: сьогодні Гран-прі Австрії.
Переможцем гонки в Шпільберзі став Шарль Леклер,
Макс Ферстаппен - другий, Льюїс Гамільтон - третій.
Мік Шумахер знову фінішував в очковій зоні, на шостому місці.
Сміливо обганяючи
свого партнера по «Хаасу» Кевіна Магнуссена,
Мік Шумахер справедливо посів шосте місце та
та гарантував собі звання гонщика дня.
Те, що ми демонструємо зараз,
сподіваюсь, і в майбутніх гонках принесе нам
багато очок.
Макс Ферстаппен стартує бездоганно,
але згодом змушений поступитися сильнішому супернику -
Шарлю Леклеру з «Фераррі».
Прямо перед фінішем змусив всіх понервувати
пілот «Фераррі» Карлос Сайнс,
який в останні секунди виліз неушкодженим
зі свого боліда, що загорівся через пошкодження двигуна.
А тепер до новин тенісу
і чергового титулу переможця
для Новака Джоковича на Вімблдоні.
Джокович обіграв у фіналі Ніка Киріоса в чотирьох сетах.
Новак Джокович - король англійських кортів.
Серб в сьомий раз здобуває перемогу
на кортах Вімблдону.
Перемозі посприяв і сам суперник Джоковича - австралієць Нік Киріос, який
часто заважав сам собі своїми
словесними перепалками, криками і претензіями.
Після програшу в першому сеті
Джокович відіграється і
реалізує на тай-брейку
у четвертому сеті свій третій матчбол.
Його 21 титул турніру Grand Slam має особливе значення.
Я обожнюю цей турнір всім серцем.
Він надихає мене продовжувати грати.
Переможний трофей йому вручила герцогиня Кейт -
наче коронація для Новака Джоковича.
Як стверджує Федеральна служба захисту конституції,
сьогодні найбільша небезпека криється у
правому тероризмі і екстремізмі,
але ці побоювання не мають довгої історії.
Те, що органи безпеки не помічали саме правого тероризму,
дослідники пояснюють фактами історії екстремізму.
Поняття тероризму в Західній Німеччині
передусім пов'язувалося з терористичною організацією RAF,
яка заявила про себе атакою державних цілей.
Праві терористи діяли інакше,
ще задовго до угрупування Націонал-соціалістичного підпілля NSU,
тут на думку спадає теракт
під час Октоберфесту 1980 року.
У той час,
коли держава була зосереджена на лівому терорі.
Цей пережиток німецької історії
у прямому значенні викидається на сміття:
сумнозвісний судовий зал у Штаммгаймі
буде знесено.
Репортаж Єви Шиллер і Ясмін Астакі-Барде.
Він називає цей зал своїм робочим кабінетом.
У той час Клаус Пфлігер був молодим прокурором і висував обвинувачення
проти RAF у 19 справах.
Судді та прокурори, яких обзивали, ображали
та яким погрожували ліві терористи,
відмічали і закреслювали для себе кожен день процесу.
Іноді ми відчували себе ніби в'язнями
у цій судовій залі -
такою напруженою і морально тяжкою була вся ситуація.
Це було протистояння, якого
в країні раніше не бачили.
50 років тому були затримані лідери
Фракції Червоної Армії RAF.
Ульріке Майнгоф, Ґудрун Енслін, Карла Распе
і Андреаса Баадера привезли на той
час у найсучаснішу в'язницю
суворого режиму у Штутґарті-Штаммгаймі.
Я не знаю, як федеральний уряд
до такого додумався.
Побудувати цю спецв'язницю, судову залу і
надати RAF такого значення,
якого в політиці у неї насправді не було.
Звинувачення у вбивстві та замаху на
вбивство у 54 справах.
Наскільки великим був тиск на правосуддя,
видно по безпрецедентних заходах безпеки
та сумнівних методах.
Наприклад, адвокатів RAF
прослуховували, а обвинувачених ізолювали.
Нестабільна правова держава,
сама того не бажаючи, допомогла злочинцям представити себе у ролі жертв.
Це тортури, саме тортури.
Пані Майнгоф, це не привід для
відкладення розгляду справи.
Спроба представити себе жертвою репресивної держави
виявилася неймовірно успішною
пропагандистською стратегією.
Для письменниці Беттіни Рьоль Штаммгайм став могилою її матері.
У 1976 році Ульріке Майнгоф
знайшли повішеною у своїй камері.
Для мене 13-річної - це був, звичайно, шок.
Просто неймовірний удар.
Ця подія мала значення не лише для мене особисто,
це була політична подія,
яка розділила світ на два табори.
Одні казали, що це вбивство,
інші - самогубство.
Через роки факт самогубств і решти лідерів RAF був доведений та
продовжував підживлювати міф про «жертв режиму»,
адже залишаються відкриті питання:
чи знала держава про заплановані суїциди,
чи прослуховували затриманих і тієї ночі?
На мою думку, зараз саме час
розвіяти останні сумніви навколо «Німецької осені».
Держава мала б терміново надати документи,
які підтверджували нелегальну, неправомірну діяльність
державних органів.
Ми зможемо лише тоді винести урок,
якщо будемо самокритичними і
і визнаємо помилки, що
це чи інше потрібно змінювати та покращувати.
Насправді мені шкода, що зносять будівлю,
яка має символічне значення.
Інвентар спецв'язниці просто піде на смітник.
Для одних буде втрачена частина німецької історії,
для інших разом зі Штаммгаймом припинить існування міф,
в якому на першому місці - злочинці, а не жертви.
А зараз огляд тем
наступного тижня від Луїзи Губен.
* Музика *
З понеділка проводитиметься технічне обслуговування
газопроводу «Північний потік-1»,
яке було заплановане завчасно і має тривати 10 днів.
В цей час газ не подаватиметься.
Чи відкриє Росія газовий кран знову -
невідомо.
Німецька благодійна організація Welthungerhilfe («Всесвітня допомога голодуючим»)
представить у вівторок
новий річний звіт.
Звіт має дати відповіді на питання,
які наслідки матиме кліматична криза,
вигнання і біженці на запаси їжі в усьому світі.
В середу президент США Байден планує
відвідати Близький Схід,
зокрема і Саудівську Аравію.
Байдена критикували за те, що він має намір
зустрітися з кронпринцом ібн Сальманом.
За даними спецслужб США, кронпринц є співучасником
у вбивстві журналіста Хашоґджі.
У четвер - річниця катастрофічної повені.
У долині річки Ар і районах Північного Рейну-Вестфалії
люди втратили свої домівки і більше сотні загинуло.
У багатьох місцях відбудуться пам'ятні заходи.
І прогноз погоди на понеділок.
Завтра буде хмарно від Північного
моря до Баварського лісу,
майже без опадів.
На решті території сонячно.
Температура підніметься до 18°-23°,
на південному заході до 28°.
У наступні дні очікується спекотна літня погода,
хмарно з проясненнями,
температура коливатиметься від 19° до 35°.
Це все на сьогодні,
дивіться далі недільний детектив.
А о 00:25 очікуйте наступний випуск «heute Xpress».
До завтра.
- До побачення.